someone like Peter doesn't
um he would admit this himself I think
doesn't follow his principles to their
absolute logical conclusion
[Music]
is our emphasis on human agency over in
Action a fantasy to justify our moral
negligence in other words do we keep
banging on about action you know because
dealing with the inaction is is tricky
and uh we get off the hook more easily
if we just focus on on action so we can
go in any order now we'll try and make
this or at least I'll try and make it
more of a conversation than a kind of
series of just Talking Heads but um I
don't know Julian do you want to maybe
pick that up and and have a go at that
yeah well I I don't I don't think the
inaction action thing is is the key
factor here I'll tell you back back onto
this I mean I think we're used to so for
example what is the thing at the moment
which perhaps most people are morally
outraged about are failure to tackle
climate change so the idea that inaction
is morally irreprehensible is absolutely
Center Stage we're very very familiar
with that I think the the question about
you know we like it is true that we like
to get off the hook and sometimes it is
true sort of thinking listen I I didn't
do it it's nothing to do with me is a
way of doing that but there are lots of
other things as well lack of proximity
Is is a key one so again if we take
Sophie's example here you know the child
labor at the end of the supply chain
well yeah I I buy something I am part of
a chain of action which has at the end
of it that the child labor when you buy
cheap coffee cheap chocolate you are
again you are actively doing something
you are contributing to a supply chain
which is ends in sort of a misery for
farmers and people like that
um so I I just think that we're very
familiar with the idea of um when we're
trying to let ourselves off the hook I
don't think
appealing to the fact that inaction
involved is it's something we sometimes
do but any way we find to distance
ourselves from the consequences of our
action or inaction we will we will often
latch onto and that's the bigger problem
rather than action in action per se I
think it's interesting you said
proximity and you talked about Supply
chains I wondered if you were going to
make the argument you didn't make which
is it depends how long the supply chain
is you know the longer it is the more
complex The More We Get Off The Hook I'm
sure you challenge that though see
what in terms of the longer the supply
chain the more the the greater the
distance the less moral responsibility
yeah sorry no I don't
um I think
um it is it's an interesting question I
actually I actually read this sort of
issue of is this is this responding to a
fantasy a slightly different I thought
you know maybe it was asking if it's a
fantasy that we've really got human
agency because if you take the supply
chain for example well actually we could
start saying well do you know what we
are we are just mired in this sort of
global now everything we do our entire
lives of you know sort of every step we
turn we would have to be you know sort
of
Billy crazy out in the desert living in
a kind of in a sort of TP of our own
fashioning to not participate in this
world
so rather and so then you might want to
go on to the conversation role how much
agency do I really have how much Choice
do I really have and that's before you
don't need to be a sort of fully fledged
Marxist to say that it's all these great
sort of social forces manipulating me
making me do this that and the other but
I wonder if there isn't a space between
Billy crazy in the desert and full-blown
everything's been determined for me and
this sort of notion of whether actually
there's a lot of intellectual work that
we could all be doing about the amounts
of choices that we can we can be making
I mean the the global supply chain is an
issue
um there are certain things that it
would be very difficult to disentangle
from our modern lives but something like
clothing
how is that is that difficult is it
difficult to say right well I'm going to
buy
predominantly second-hand clothes you
know I'm going to make a positive
decision to do that or you know I
suppose it is about coming back to
having a look at what you do have to
work with without saying that you've got
full and complete agency to determine
absolutely everything you do so it's
that sort of I suppose I'd like to very
negotiated
actions into this mixture okay thank you
and maybe we'll pick up on that actually
Peter I wondered uh about your thoughts
I'm taken with your notion of the person
living in the desert and Peter I mean
I'm sure in your work you've explored
this theme you know is that just a
fantasy that there is somewhere we could
go to be completely off-grid and
completely non-culpable in any way of
any sort of moral implication or
negative moral implication of our
actions
oh you could probably do it if you tried
hard enough but I'm not sure that that's
the best thing to do because then you're
not going to be presumably earning as
much as you would if you're a part of
this society and therefore you're
foregoing the opportunity to contribute
to one of the highly effective Charities
who are helping people in extreme
poverty and I think we do have agency I
mean the supply chain issues are
difficult I agree it's hard to find out
whether your clothes did involve child
labor or the Laborer of uyghurs in China
for example something like that that's
that requires quite a lot of
Investigation but it's you know anybody
who's middle class or above in a country
like the United Kingdom or the United
States or Australia
um has spare resources that they can
contribute to effective organizations
and thanks to the work of the effective
altruism movement you can now go online
you can go to the life you can save if
you like which is a a website an
organization that I founded or you can
go to give well or others and you can
find independently assessed Charities
that have been determined to be highly
effective in taking our donation and
helping people in extreme poverty in a
variety of ways maybe giving out bed
nets so children don't die of malaria
maybe restoring sight in people who have
cataracts and can't afford to get them
removed a whole lot of different things
so I think we we do have agency and I
don't think we should go and live in the
desert I think we should do our best to
contribute to change through our
personal donations and of course through
our political activity as well in
democracies we can help to make a change
that way well I feel a bit like a
presenter on The Today Show trying to
get a fierce argument going and yet
they're sort of quite broad agreement
here that we should we should also do
our best here so I'm going to try and
provoke maybe I'll try and provoke you
Julian so like surely we can't be such
goody goodies all the time can we yeah
no no I mean I think there is I do have
disagreement
um I think the disagreement is this is
that
I think the kind of approach that Peter
Advocates which is only sort of begun to
sort of sketch out so it's not something
he's overtly said today really takes us
its premise the idea that when we're
thinking about what our moral
responsibilities are we have a duty to
kind of consider everybody's interests
absolutely equally with no with no favor
at all so the fact that someone is um
your neighbor uh a member of your family
and so forth there may be pragmatic
reasons why you would spend more time
helping them than people the other side
of the world namely that you're there
you're available so they're practical
reasons that's not a principle in
principle our responsibilities are
equally the same to everybody and I I
don't think that that's sustainable I
think that it sort of has it has a view
of human nature and society which is
um I don't think it it is an accurate
view of human nature and Society I think
that the duties and responsibilities we
have are often a result of historical
even geographical political accidents
and these these these responsibilities
this is not extend
universally now the point is I I could
argue that point in a philosophical
nitpicking way and I'd probably you know
Peter's a agreement would probably
destroy me but um in a way I wouldn't
even want to because I think you don't
need to because in practice I think we
tend to converge in practice someone
like Peter doesn't
um he would admit this himself I think
doesn't follow his principles to their
absolute logical conclusion Peter does
not live literally on the minimum that
he could survive on
um any less than which he'd become
miserable
um he is very very generous indeed he
gives away a lot of money he won the 1
million pound but good om Prize last
year gave it all away so he does he's a
much more altruistic person than I will
ever be so I'm not being critical but in
practice no one can really live the way
that Peter Advocates it's an ideal he
aspires to I don't think we need to have
the unrealistic ideal in order to say in
virtue of being part of an
interconnected world where you know we
can no longer pretend that our actions
only affect our neighbors and the people
in our street we have much much greater
responsibility towards you know the
people in the supply chains people in
the developing world than we think we
have but
it's the same we have exactly the same
responsibility as to everyone I think
that undermines the the special nature
of the relationships we have with
certain people Family Friends Community
and so forth
um Peter it's not my job to look after
your feelings but I'm just wondering
after that uh whether you're feeling
more condemned or praised and whether
you feel like you've been characterized
more as a man a principle or not
uh look at what Julian said is quite
right you know I don't live at that
absolute limit of what I could give away
um and uh I think Julian is also right
that human nature is to a significant
degree goes against the ideal that I've
been putting out there but what I'm
trying to do is to encourage people to
do more and to that extent despite
you're trying to get a disagreement
between me and Julia it's not really
that clear cut because
um you know I'm trying to push people in
this direction and I
um I'm certainly prepared to say that if
Julian is saying we should do more than
we're Allied on on that issue the
question is really just uh what's the
best way to get people to try and push
against those natural impulses that we
have to a certain degree but I don't
expect and I wouldn't myself
um you know assume people can be
completely impartial between their
spouses their parents their children
um and and distant strangers okay
um Sophie we'll in a second we'll move
on to the next question but I I'd love
you to respond to this again I'll sign
up the anteater a little bit here but
you know Julian's basically saying we
should have a rank order of people we
should help who would be on the top of
your list
right well um yeah it's an it's
interesting I I
do have a quite quite serious point
about this because and it might be in
slight um differentiation because whilst
obviously
um you have to kind of work in the
situation you're in but and therefore if
what you can do is give money to certain
Charities and you know that is how
you're going to register a general vague
broad solidarity with the world sorts of
thing that's good but where does that
come from I wonder if it comes from up
here you know you're that that's a sort
of you know you are you're doing it's
taking the reasons approach to this I
think it is a generally good thing to be
on the the side of humanity I'm
interested in
um Julian's elderly parents that
emotional entanglement really that sort
of kind of drops away some of the
language about you know moral decision
making it's not a moral decision you
have to do it and that really you know
that sense of being I I guess I'm
curious and I'd be interested to know
what um Peter and Julian think about you
know where is this in that picture like
how we are are we able to really feel
for that this this poor hypothetical
child that we're picking on Whose life
is already hard enough but who has
become the subject of of our of our
conversation like how do we sort of
restore that kind of emotional energy
that makes it not even a question of you
know a sort of ethical auditing if you
like like well I can do this and I
should do this and by the time it's more
practical for me to do this and that
kind of neat balance sheet of choices
um where does that kind of
and this come brings me back to the
apathy issue I suppose it's like what
was going on with that why why weren't
all those young people in the mid 50s
later on obviously that changed but why
weren't they all getting furious about
the bomb maybe they were but maybe there
was a sort of degree of which you know
we are living in a world which makes it
very easy to become emotionally
paralyzed a lot of the time there's only
so much crap we can take thing after
thing after thing after thing and it's
like that's actually to me an extremely
dangerous situation to get into because
if morality and ethics becomes purely a
matter of accounting I don't think
that's a very I don't think that's a
very promising Future Okay
um thank you I've got there are sort of
two other key questions that we're going
to try and focus in before
opening out to questions which are
developments really of where we've
already been
um first of these is
so would emphasizing the failure to act
lead to a fairer Society for all in
other words we you know if we really
called out inaction
um which of the three of you would like
to have a go at this first
um
yes Peter go ahead
Society yes because I think uh it's in
action it's you know there's this huge
disparity we're all very aware of
between uh the low-income countries and
particularly those in extreme poverty in
the low-income countries
um and uh as I say those who are middle
class or above in affluent countries
um and yet we're most people are doing
very little so I think if we
um got rid of or lessened at least I
kind of agree we can't get rid of it
entirely but if we lessen this divide
between action and inaction that would
change and and Julian mentioned climate
change and that's that's a really good
example
um because in well in fact maybe it's
it's a case where we're not seeing I
think what we're doing as actions right
but but when we emit greenhouse gases we
are harming people
um but we think totally differently that
we don't have the you know Sophie was
talking about the emotional responses if
if you went to somebody in a distant
country and and punched them in the face
so that they you know were really badly
hurt
um everybody would say that was a
horrendous thing to do if you're a mid
greenhouse gases that might mean that
they can no longer produce crops because
they're there's a drought or their land
is flooded or it's too hot to work and
at the Harvest Time
um you know that we don't attribute
responsibility for in in the same way
yeah
um it's interesting it made me think you
know we have crimes of neglect talking
about you know child care and families
earlier we don't have crimes of neglect
at least yet necessarily with regard to
The Climate what were you thinking now I
think there's some this this concept is
a moral estrangement is a is a sort of
um really interesting one for me and
this notion of whether if we then
started taking tougher stances on an
action what what would happen to that
would it would it exacerbate it or would
it ameliorate it and honestly I mean it
is going to be a very contextual thing
so something like the climate change yes
absolutely you know that I I don't think
you could make sort of broad
generalizations for that issue
absolutely but for other issues My worry
is who's doing the deciding about what
actions are good and desirable and how
they what they are who should be taking
them in to what degree and who's
deciding which inactions are punishable
and by what means and how exactly and
I'm very I'm very very worried about
unless this is an utterly kind of
democratic in the fullest and strongest
sense of that term conversation then um
that is a kind of
that is an additional feature of an
increasingly sort of punitive
interventionist political state which is
already judging individuals very very
strongly very harshy and a very
um invasive way okay what do you think
well I mean I'm thinking that again I
think the whole inaction action thing is
actually it's a difficult concept it
depends on the framing so it's
interesting you know Peter was talking
about climate change in action and he
said well actually we've got to see it
as being mainly about action we're
pumping the gases out Etc the very same
thing can be framed as an action or
inaction if I don't give food to my
children am I starving them that sounds
like an action am I letting them starve
right I mean it's semantic isn't it I
actually think if you emphasize inaction
I don't think that's going to get to
people as much as if you rather draw
attention to the consequences of their
actions and the other thing is it's not
so much inaction that's a problem as the
refusal to kind of change the actions we
have so I think what people have to
recognize is that we are constantly
engaged in actions every day in actions
where we invest our pensions where we
buy our food
um and it's not just about the consumer
end as well I think that's a big mistake
to think the key to this is just make
sure you spend your money in the right
way you know the things that we take to
be political priorities and so forth you
know a lot of the the harms that are
done in the world are because it is set
up in a certain way where certain
actions are taken to be the norm they
have the consequences and they're not
being challenged so it's switching from
one set of actions to another rather
than sort of like saying you're not
doing enough right we're doing the kind
of things that Peter's concerned about
are often the consequence of actual
um actions that have been done
historical actions colonial actions etc
etc they're not just people aren't
starving simply because no one's
bothered to do anything it's often
because they have bothered to do
something they just bother to do the
things which are highly extractive and
highly harmful and highly unfair
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas